your boy right over your shoulder right
there yeah he's just got bigger ears
than i do
the eye but the eyes are remarkably
similar
that's why years
working on that yeah with the animation
team we
a lot of eye scans
oh my god that's very cool though that's
very cool it's going to be a big thing
for like the kids i would imagine the
kids think that's kind of cool oh i'm
much uh
i've got more street cred at the dinner
table now that i'm in in the sinks
we went years and people would say
what's your what's your kid's favorite
film you've done i was like they haven't
seen any i haven't made money they can
see so finally making something they can
see
they dig them they still they they know
i made it
but yet when we got to the theater to
watch it and they see buster moon come
on the voice comes out think it sounds
like it's their dad they look over at me
they look back at the screen look over
at me look back at the screen look over
at me black at the screen then they get
a big smile on their face
hey i have a big one with clay
no one's seen it for 15 years i'll give
you three weeks to get this show up and
running i won't let you down sir better
not or i'll throw you off the roof
what do you think it is about these
films that kids and families in
particular love
um well look a lot of animated films are
the kids drag us to them we're like okay
i'll do it
if you can get one that
i want to go to that my mother and my
grandmother also want to go to where the
kids can sing along i got on my songs i
can sing along to it and my grandparents
have songs they can sing along to it
then you've got something for the whole
family which is what we have here with
this i mean watching the films they're
very reminiscent of like the at least
the first one anyway the uh the american
idols the voice the reality singing
competitions have you ever been asked to
participate in one of those
no would you like to be
asked yeah to participate yeah as a
contestant
even like a for a one-off or a singer or
any other one is there a reality
competition show that you watch that
you're like you know what doing that
would be pretty fun
oh
naked afraid
you know what honestly what i thought i
was like naked and afraid or it would be
like naked and chill i don't feel like
you get afraid that those things would
be hard
no i like i like to sing but not uh um
only in the shower i like that uh before
i let you go uh hopped on your instagram
lovely chat with uh
miss hudson the other day finally
cleared up the the worst kisser
she knew that all along she was just
telling that talking out of school on me
yeah yeah i didn't say you were my worst
kisser
i read it i just read it what is it
about your friendship with her that you
really appreciate
she's fun to work with
yeah she's she's fun she's she's rock
and roll we get in there and we
you know romantic comedies action
comments we've done together the man on
the femor whoever the two leads are they
have to have some kind of chemistry that
you go i buy that i
want to be there and
we we pulled that off a few times i
think and that's what we like working
working with each other you fooled me to
win a bet and you should feel ashamed
look you took me to a goddamn celine
dion concert you made me miss the big
game
oh smart guy's a rhymer well do we want
everybody to know your love making is
live oh maybe because you name it it's
gonna take to get you guys back together
on screen again not on instagram write
script write script right movie i like
it yeah what are the holiday plans in
the mcconaughey home family we've got
all my family and we have all of
camilla's family so we have the
brazilians and the texans americans
together
happy holidays congratulations on this
thank you thank you
merry christmas